[Music]
joining me today is the former CEO of
National Public Radio and the author of
Republican like me how I left the
liberal bubble and learn to love the
right kenster and welcome to the Rubin
report thanks Dave thanks for adding me
on the show
you left the liberal bubble and have
survived I did you're a survivor so live
on 94 percent Democratic ninety-four
percent Democratic Ward in Washington
you see 100% Democratic household
increasingly concerned about this when
they kick you out of the house so under
debate and my ten year old son booed my
first television appearance when the
book came out and I've been creasing ly
concerned about sort of the polarization
how much we hate the other side often
without really knowing the other side so
I decided I'd spend I'd do something
about it for myself
recognizing I am in a bubble like all of
us are I wanted to spend time as much as
I can it could trying to understand
things from some of the things from the
someone else's point of view that's been
a year traveling the country communing
with conservatives with Republicans
really trying to see things from their
point of view yeah and that did survive
so yeah or we get well you've survived
so far let's see it let's see how this
hour okay and there's a lot that I want
to talk to you about because even the
use of the word liberal in the subtitle
I think is interesting because I always
talk about the difference between the
left and liberalism and and a few other
things but first let's just find out a
little bit about your your back story
what we are doing that led you to be the
the CEO of NPR so I've spent a good part
of my career in media spent on some
international broadcasting Voice of
America and joined NPR in 1999 a first
as chief operating officer and then
eventually became CEO and was there
during it for about a decade have spent
time in almost all the unpopular
professions there are law politics and
media so
and you're from DC right so he's having
the whole thing here yeah so there's a
there's a lot to dislike about my
background
apparently for most of the country tell
me a little bit about just the NPR
machine I know half my audience to my
audience that leans right is probably
hearing NPR and they're going oh I like
this guy because he left the bubble butt
but NPR like raises some flags for them
and then my audience on the left is
going NPR they're the they're the the
new Bible of truth and all that tell me
a little bit about just the ecosystem of
NPR so and parents interesting place it
is a really collective of public radio
stations from around the country so NPR
is a company which I ran for for a
number of years of journalists and
similar people it's essentially a news
organization but it is connect to do 500
public radio stations around the country
so it's unique in the sense that you
know most of its reporters are located
watching you see in similar places but
you can go to virtually any community
around the country the wilds of Alaska
you'll find public radio stations which
I think makes it sort of a unique place
yeah do they have any other connection
the radio stations other than that they
fall under the NPR well they're all
they're all part of the not NPR they're
all part of the public radio system and
the thing that often people key on is
that they are not through NPR through
the corporation public broadcasting the
recipients of various federal funds
support their operations yeah what does
it say that if we were to look at all of
these radio stations that I would guess
that probably every single one of them
leans left yet they're funded by the
government so this isn't this isn't a
nonpartisan radio operation really right
yeah so I've made myself somewhat
unpopular in public radio over the last
few months by saying two things which I
think you can hold in your head at the
same time I actually have a lot of it
admiration for virtually all the
reporters I know at NPR and poetry
stations they try to do tell stories
from both sides they're dedicated to the
craft of journalism sometimes I think
they are often even to almost metronome
like and here's one point of view here's
another and so I think it is appropriate
to acknowledge that they are serious
journalism doing journalists
be balanced and fair to appropriate a
slogan from Fox right I think the
challenge that I raised with emoji made
me unpopular is they all probably not
offer many of them come from the same
these are self-perpetuating
organizations they hire people who are
like them who tend to think like them
came from similar backgrounds all
problem many of them I think if you took
a census of them you'd find very few
vote for Donald Trump right it's funny I
can see how carefully you're trying to
be with your words that you don't want
to say all and of course you don't mean
every into e there but it's probably the
vast vast majority if not 90% or more
our progressives I think is basically
what you're trying I think that probably
right and so I mean so I think the
challenge is not that they're
progressives but there is a consequence
of group think about what story is
important what what policies are right
and wrong what what voices should be on
the air and I think that's a real
challenge for a place like NPR and
really for mainstream media as a whole
you know it's what I said to the folks
at NPR was you know they would never
think of covering racial issues only
with white males no matter how good
those white males are and really should
be the same with with politics they
shouldn't cover it only with people who
largely come from a progressive
background no matter how dead here the
craft of journalism
what kind of racial if she'd be made
where well it doesn't matter I just mean
any sort of you know if they wanted to
cover you know if they had a beat on
race in America right they would not
only have they wouldn't it just wouldn't
have whites on it white males only on
and they shouldn't it shouldn't cover
gender issues okay with men I mean I
think you need to have people of
different backgrounds and different
ideas to have the right type of creative
tension that a newsroom needs right
you're not saying exclude those people
you're saying they just no of course not
I'm all for white male last I checked
yeah you know they it's it's it's that
you need to have not only diversity of
gender and race in in newsroom you have
to diversity of ideas and backgrounds
yeah so where were your politics so you
started there in 99 were you a hardcore
lefty were you a centrist yeah liberal
or I don't think a hardcore person who
write the book I
and take the experience but I spent time
to democratic politics on the reelect
for Bill Clinton I think you know I
think I say in the book my voted
straight Democratic ticket except for I
think I probably voted against Barry and
Barry in his various quest to be mayor
for life and that's about it so the
crack arrest was too much for you that's
where you drew the line with Marion
Barry yes that's right that's right yeah
so when did you sort of start realizing
that there was this ideological lockdown
on alternative opinions there you mean
it so I think there's an alternative
lockdown and ideas generally yes does
not make this about NPR one place
because I think that's unfair because
what has happened in this country is
we've all become in our own bubbles
liberals conservatives and it's it's a
product of a number of different things
that's going on it's really quite
extraordinary it's we now choose where
we live based upon political ideology
and try to find homogeneous
neighborhoods politically homogeneous
neighborhoods it didn't exist before our
political parties are increasingly
political home homogeneous there no such
thing as conservative Democrats or
liberal Republicans anymore they don't
have homes yeah where's the Blue Dog
Democrats go they are the guys that I
would love to be voted right they died I
mean the Blue Dog caucus was quite
important 15 years ago yeah doesn't
exist anymore there is no Democrat who
is more conservative than the than the
most liberal Republican and vice versa
they're the Venn diagram does not meet
anymore in the Congress and now we lower
all of our own media right so concerns
Gillison Fox or any other or rush or any
other place Democrats had liberals and
progressives have plenty of choices that
fit their own and it's a credibly
destructive and it means we're all
increasing their own bubble and when
that happens it's not that we actually
begin to disagree more become easy just
easy to demonize the other side when you
don't know them or you don't hear from
them when you don't dialogue with them
it's really easy to hate each other and
that's what's happened this country we
really hate the other side in ways that
are very different than 15 years ago
well I think that's why I do this show
and why you wrote this book
but before we get out of the fully the
radio part of it yeah you mentioned rush
why does it seem
right-wing radio so rush and Glenn back
and michaelsavage and the list goes on
and on seems to be commercially viable
gets tons of listens and all that and
left-wing radio it simply doesn't work
outside of what's funded really by the
government so Air America was a
catastrophe
right right example I don't have a good
answer that so let's let me admit up
front I don't think it's a good answer
I'll tell you what conservatives will
say they will say I don't think this is
either I think it's a little bit truth a
little bit of falsehood in is what
liberals find a home a place like the
New York Times and NPR they're
comfortable with him there their needs
are met and they'll say that Rush and
others cessful because conservative
needs are not met in mainstream media
yeah and that's you know I'm not gonna
make an equivalency between left and
right I think that's a false equivalency
in terms of media and how they operate
but it is clearly true when you look at
the the psychographics of the of the
readers and your times or the listeners
NPR they come primarily from the left
yeah when you hear people on the right
it's usually people on the right say
well why are we funding NPR I mean why
is the government and even funding
public radio at all at this point and
especially if there is an ideological
bent to it how do you respond yeah again
I don't want to let's not take this too
far because it ideological bent is is
right in sort of an unconscious way a
subconscious way it doesn't have I think
no one sits at NPR ordinary we didn't
used to and says you know let's tell one
side of the story and not the other yeah
I suspect that's actually not quite true
I mean I think they're in their bubble
as you talked about here so much that I
don't know that they're consciously
doing it but they've sort of decided
what yeah I think it's everything I
think it's a fair criticism right but
there's a difference I mean there's a
very significant difference in how
mainstream media works and conservative
media works and let's just acknowledge
it without sort of attributed anything
good or bad to it and some knowledge
that they come from a different place
and a different sort of journalistic
ethic you know a public fraud funding
for broadcast public broadcasting is an
artifact of a different era you know
they they started in 1970
when there was three networks and there
were just no real alternatives to those
three networks and a handful of
newspapers and it was really important
that the government as they do in
England in a lot of other places
supported the public radio and public
televsion and they exist I'm probably
true that if if Paul grade and Public
Television did exist no one would create
it now because there's so many different
outlets the reason is I think it's
interesting though to actually explore
the reasons why public broadcasting
funding still exists it's not because of
NPR and PBS it's because of the local
stations the people who's you know don't
bang on NPR and PBS but those at least
in my day the people who actually stood
up for public broadcasting when it came
to appropriation time it was Ted Stevens
as conservative a senator you ever get
from Alaska because he didn't really
care for NPR more psp2 but he loved
Alaska problem broadcasting and he knew
that that was election a lifeline
lifeline brought service to parts of
Alaska that didn't get content local
news and others and that's why I think
it still gets pokes but um spoke support
not because of like or dislike for the
National content providers that's
interesting I don't know too much about
Ted Stevens specifically but I wonder
was he fighting would he been okay with
well let let's the state fund it then
you know not instead of the federal
government or is it's all funded I
assume is it is a partnership parley
with the states with put ups it so
public broadcasting is complicated but
yeah states we don't have to go to do
you think it's interesting
relative to so many not all many
broadcasting stations get significant
support from local jurisdictions whether
it's a state or a municipality
yeah so even though he probably wasn't
thrilled with what they were putting on
air he just wanted some of the federal
funds that help allow it because he
liked it for his state's purposes yeah
he knew it was a lifeline service to
Alaska and Wyoming and other places like
that they don't have major media markets
that's really who and that's where the
money goes is to those stations right
it's interesting because the world has
changed so much obvious so 1970 and the
idea that the government I mean to me
and I get it Sesame Street's great and I
was just watching it with my niece a
couple weeks ago but the idea that the
government is funding any of these ways
that we get media now you know seems
very archaic to where we are in 2017 it
is you know the interesting to think
about and we can spend the whole hour
talking about it and hope we don't get
my book yeah we'll get there but if
federal funding went away tomorrow on
the radio side I know much more about
regular in television NPR ultimately
fine
many of the stations in big cities would
be fine it's actually the rural stations
that would collapse mm-hmm
and that's why you know I think there is
that support for public broadcasting
funding as it goes forward yeah just
generally speaking do you think that if
funding was slowed down or cut or
whatever that wouldn't private people
that feel that this is important jump in
on that I mean that's one of the themes
that I talk about here a lot about how
much should the government do and if the
government stopped doing so much maybe
if these things are vital and important
that private people would and they
didn't take on some of the burden yeah
uh great at all I think principled
support I mean ten years out of date so
at least when I was there the principal
revenue came from listeners like you
yeah that's where the the largest source
of revenue comes from so as the host of
the PBS fundraiser in New York City yeah
Manhattan right many years ago I gave
away some totes and all that data for
free yeah no yeah so again I think
wooden in New York WNYC would be fine
they probably hate me for saying this
but I don't know that poll asked a
public radio would be fine because the
amount of people to give them money
pretty pretty low I'm just a number of
people and the wealth available tap is
is very different there yeah it's just
an interesting dilemma because I could
see some valuable stations in these
local markets these small markets that
there's worth to them and then on the
other hand it's like why should we be
funding all of these things if they
can't just exist on their own so it's an
interesting philosophical a because it's
one those issues which I think if
conservatives talk to conserve is about
and liberals talk to liberals about they
come to very different points of view
yeah if you actually talk to people who
know and put people together actually
realize it's actually a fairly
complicated nuanced issue that has no
sort of obvious right or wrong answer
it's actually true when you go out and
talk to people about issues people
actually you know in social media
they're angry and mad but no life
actually pretty moderate and that's one
of the things I discovered in my year
traveling the country yeah well people
are always there seemingly worst online
and snappiest and very rarely do that
you know when you're standing across
somebody or sitting across somebody just
like this so let's talk about the word
liberal for a second the subtitle is how
I left the liberal bubble and learn to
love the right yeah what does liberal
mean to you so I think that's a
catch-all phrase for progressive
Democrat in some type of gross way
describe Democrats progressive people of
the left I don't mean necessarily
classical liberal as you might be
thinking of it yeah has it meant because
I think today it means it's the
catch-all for I know it's a very poor
ssin of the of the spectrum yeah it's
unfortunate for me because I've tried
really hard to show people that if
you're a classical liberal and you
believe in the individual and
live-and-let-live that actually that is
virtually nothing to do with
progressives but even even some of my
allies now who are on the right well we
say liberal liberal liberal and of my
guys let's separate from left but yeah
yeah I don't know if I gave it that
careful thought the ends of the term I
mean I think it's a catch-all for the
people whose environment I was shared
yeah who I lived with the people I
worked with the people who ran the
meteor ization is that I used yeah did
you find those people to actually be
liberal though I know this is a little
bit about the definition of the words
but did you find that they really at
their heart were liberal I mean that
they really were tolerant and
understanding and liberalism in its best
sense good god no and I think this gets
us to where the book is yeah I think the
thing that's worried me absolute truth
it's one of which is I think that's
share we're increasingly intolerant of
anyone who disagrees with us it's strong
airily so and it is angered me a little
bit so ruining me personally because
I've always thought of like you thought
of liberals one of the tenants of modern
liberalism is tolerance of perspective
different perspective and belief that
really we need
the diversity of ideas and there is
value in different ideas and value in
listening and engaging that is not a
value of modern American politics as we
know it and that is her wounds me
personally and one of the things that
led me to this book yeah do you remember
a moment when you started seeing that
more amongst your kind so to speak so
I'll tell you story no not particularly
I think there are lots in us but I'll
tell you a story that's got beyond going
in the book yeah which is a story of my
neighbor and Washington DC I live in a
nice neighborhood called Mount Pleasant
94% Democratic Ward the the Green Party
candidate al pol Donald Trump in the
last election and you know it's a nice
diverse neighborhood we value our
diversity but we don't it's always been
obvious we make jokes about we'd never
really valued political diversity
obviously so but it really hit home to
me on something called the Hobart Street
pledge that's the name of the street I
live in it's a very got a lot team
spirit on Hobart Street we have lots of
block parties we close the street a
Halloween and our biggest block parties
called porch fest and has a parade and
every year it starts with the Hobart
Street pledge and I always loved the
idea of the Hobart Street pledge to the
kids sort of pledge allegiance to Hobart
Street Northwest right and change every
year in one year it went I pledge
allegiance to Hobart Street Northwest
yada yada yada
everyone is welcome on Hobart Street
white white or black gay or straight man
or woman everyone but Republicans and it
was a joke but it wasn't a joke man and
I wrote a media article for the
Atlantica about it but it really got me
thinking about how have we come to a
place where we can value diversity but
not viewpoint diversity and that's I
think where we are as a country and
let's say you know what I'm not all that
different I have the same sort of
prejudice against the other side
let me test that in some interesting
ways so how did you start testing that
so you know so so it that's a challenge
like okay how do you actually see things
from the other point of view so over a
course veer I did so tons of different
things I went to Trump rallies and spent
Tea Party meetings and went pig hunting
in Texas spent more time than the rest
of my life combined in church mostly the
Evangel evangelical churches I got
adopted by a Assembly of God
congregation in Fredericksburg Virginia
I went you know spent time working class
bars in Youngstown Ohio and went to coal
mining country went in a tour I've
thought of all the places I thought I
should hate like Liberty University and
you know on hunting trips and gun shows
and Texas and really found out I didn't
hate them and they didn't hate me and
that actually you know we disagreed on a
lot of things with the people I met but
eight things out of ten we probably saw
eye to eye on whether he's actually
talking and that was a real lesson work
she's surprisingly moderate people you
just wouldn't know it from the the media
environment we all live in so what's it
like to show up in these places how'd
you do it did you just walk into a
church and go guys um I'm here to make
sure I don't hate ya what's going on
here I did it's exactly what I did so
I'm a couple interesting experiences I
went to a evangelical Jamboree for a
Jamboree for evangelical youths 15,000
um called Urbana in in a football
stadium in st. Louis I managed to get an
invitation to that and spent two days
listening kids talk about you know their
the issues that I want talking about
abortion and gay rights but they want to
talk about you want to talk about black
lives matter they want to talk about
refugees how to help them not how to
keep them out and so a little bit of a
preconception destroying experience and
then I went to churches so I emailed
pastor Steve so actually tell you how I
ended up with the pastor seat so I had a
sort of a a rabbi that's maybe not the
right term when we talk about
evangelicals in the evangelical
community guy a professor at Washington
University Law School named John and Naz
ooh and he said I told him I went to one
of the big ventricle mega churches and I
sort of proudly told him that he said
well you know that's great but you need
to go to an evangelist Emily of God
Church you know with 50 members to
really see the real sore heart of
evangelicalism like what the hell am I
gonna find that I live in Washington C
and I googled evangelical churches
Washington see someone you know
in sort of desperation hmm turned out
there were like a hundred congregations
within 50 miles no idea about it so I
randomly picked one had had a service
time that appealed to me and emailed
pastor Steve and said I'd write a book
I'd like to come was a little hesitant
but you know he opens his door to
everyone and I probably went down there
half a dozen times in Fredericksburg
Virginia and essentially pastor Steve
and I actually have almost the same sort
of biography in some ways we were the
same age were born in the same area had
very different paths in life but we
actually both have a wife and one son
who's this happens to be the same age we
had a lot in common very different
thoughts in life and what's important
but a lot in common you know when I
think of pastor Steve I think of you
know someone who I really admire and you
know when people all des portray
everyone on the right as deplorable I
think a pastor Steve did a lot of other
people I met and I know that description
is just flat wrong yeah so you go to the
churches now were you just sort of
watching from the back or did you
actually be on the pastor I mean did you
start interviewing people did they know
you were writing a book yeah they were
kind enough to actually put together
focus groups so like the second time I
went pastor Steve put together like ten
members of the congregation and I sort
of sat in a in their you know their
lunch room in the basement and we talked
for an hour about politics and community
and things like that you know people
actually extraordinarily welcoming
that's one of the other things the they
wanted to talk they feel a lot of people
want talking about media I mean just
like you did yeah because they feel
locked out I mean that wasn't there
talking about media as I listen but they
feel locked out from the national media
and that frustration I was a good person
to express that frustration to yeah
were you shocked that they were as
welcoming and friendly I mean it's
almost sounds silly to have to ask that
question but I think a lot of lefties a
lot of progressives actually think that
these are all evil people
did it shock you so let me tell you a
story so the Washington Post did a word
cloud I think about a year or two ago
which they as Democrats what you thought
about Republicans and Republicans what
you thought about Democrats
and then they sort of put a put it up
visually in all the words on both sides
were terribly nasty Democrats thought
you know Republicans were bigoted cheap
selfish racist and that was two years
ago I'm sure they're much worse now
right yeah yeah so so I sort of
challenged myself like I didn't believe
that but I sorta believed it yeah what
were the words though that Democrats
said about Republicans do you remember
that race I'm sorry the other way around
that Republican I don't remember but
they were all unflattering I think
stupid intolerant lid tired yeah right
snowflake is all before that right or
that whole lingo I learned that lingo
from Breitbart so I had to admit myself
that somewhere you know deep down I
probably had those home prejudice
because they're not accurate and I sort
of carried me with them even as I was
trying to be open-minded and
open-hearted in the journey so you know
it was didn't shock me that people were
people were people and they cared about
the same things I care about and wanted
to talk but you know I also know that it
was preconception busting if I have to
be perfectly honest about it yeah give
me another anecdote or two of wandering
around things that sort of hit you that
became sort of the seminal moments of
this yeah so so I wanted against or the
challenge of what what do you do to sort
of be in the shoes of a conservative
it's not I mean you can watch Fox and
you can read breitbart and do a lot of
different things but how do you
experience it so you know NASCAR races
but one thing so I read an article in
The Washington Post
apparently I still worried the
Washington Post and it was it had a
quote from the head of heritage action
I heard foundation action who said you
know the people in the cell Accord are
missing the awesomeness of America I
said that's right that's me I've been
the excel quarter I need to find the
awesomeness America so I knew Tucker
Carlson a little bit and I went to see
Tucker right Norrell and I said all
right tell me how to find the
awesomeness of America you should know
even though he's from the same South
Corridor I am and he said sort of
puzzling then he started you should go
pig hunting in Texas all right I'll go
pig hunting in Texas
so I spent sorry I did that it's part of
you know my challenge I want to
challenge myself an issue that I didn't
know a lot about but I was sure I was
right and gun control and gun rights so
what was your position at that time when
we started here I'm for all for
virtually every form of gun control
imaginable up to if I could figure out a
way to take everyone's guns I would
probably been for it that's was your
previous position that was a previous
matter now we'll get to here and you
have this experience so I went hunting
so I wouldn't pick on the attacks it
learned out you know some people should
have a gun in some shouldn't and I'm on
the shouldn't side because I'm more than
that in danger but you know it's in the
more than your first time I'm actually
holding a gun my first time holding
shooter that I that's I went to a skeet
range in Prince George County the week
before to test it but that essentially
that experience was the first time in
the morning I ended up with a
three-generation family from Georgia
Isaac CJ and paps the grandfather and I
end up actually with Isaac who is a 10-8
it was sort of my hunting companion and
so it was sort of he was the mentor in
that because he knew how to hunt and he
was sort of gently guided me through the
hunting process and we had a great time
together and you know we told stories
hunting even though I didn't have
stories of hunting and you want to tell
how he shot the out of pigs yeah
this day and the afternoon I ended up
with what I call sort of a demographic
version of a bar bar joke a black guy
from Houston former spanic former
soldier and a Serbian immigrant and me a
Jew from Washington we were the hunting
group yeah and we had a great time we
talked about guns and their community
and what their why they cared about guns
and it's a great experience and that's
the call of John Locke the conservative
economist and said all right convince me
why I'm so wrong they did I mean when
you talk to real experts and you talk to
real people and real experts you better
be open to learning a little bit yeah
they're a lot all right let's pause on
economics for a second and so funny as
you're describing this I mean basically
you're writing the the plot when you do
the screenplay on this to city slickers
three I mean it's your Billy Crystal
yeah go pig hunting this time instead of
you know Rassilon combustion yeah
right right so you have these
experiences you seem to you like the
people did you find any diversity of
thought on that side I mean it sounds
like it was mostly at first about well
they were nice that's that's pretty good
yeah did you see were they all in
lockstep intellectually the way you were
sort of frustrated with that so here's
so yeah I think people live so I think
people lived a conservative bubble - and
tend to gravitate towards each other the
truth in matters I mean but the truth in
matter is most people don't actually
spend a lot of time thinking about these
issues I mean the media saturated my
hometown the swamp of Washington
saturated ninety percent of the country
is not spending their time worried about
the details of the tax bill or whether
Jerusalem should be the location for the
American Embassy in Israel or not
they're worried about the community
they're worried about family they're
worried about the Youngstown State
football team more than they are worried
about that and part of the sort of I
think the the fallacy of modern media
and political insider is that the
beliefs that everyone cares about the
same things we do they don't they're
really cared about their local issues
and their local in their family matters
and that's you know really what they
want to talk about and you know the the
charge like I hear from a lot of my
liberal friends or progressive friends
that everyone voted for Trump bar is you
know either agrees with Trump or is a
racist like Trump or whatever not truly
I mean people just don't pay attention
on the same levels that I do that you do
and others and I think a lot of the
conversations was I showed diversity of
thought because most people don't
actually spend a lot of time thinking
about it when you actually talked about
are you forgotten people don't fall
neatly into are you for guns or you
against guns actually tend to gravitate
towards the middle when you actually
start talking about is this a reasonable
gun control idea is this you know do you
really want to confiscate guns people
gravitate towards the middle in real
life just not in the media world yeah so
let's talk a little bit about your
evolution then so as someone that was
pretty radical in a certain sense on
guns beforehand I mean they were saying
almost get rid of them
yeah now you go out you're hunting pigs
in Texas
yeah a good eight year old yeah then
what happens so eventually I came to the
conclusion you know
so I came not an acolyte of John lot
because that's not not correct that
Chris I some of his work in my book but
I was persuaded by sort of the the
effectiveness he so so John Lott is a
it's not a gun rights guy he's a public
safety guy and the challenge he put to
me was explained to me how so many of
these gun control measures that you
believe are fantastic actually would
change things and as I dived with him
and then separately into the data
understood that you know how these
things actually work it it actually
taught me one things one is that most of
the things that you know people stand up
for gun control don't actually work
don'ting the laws themselves those were
the proposals for further restrictions
on gun gun use generally won't have any
impact and secondly I think even more
importantly um people have forgotten
that the murder rate with using guns in
this country has fallen half over the
last twenty years as we've been arguing
over here about gun control or gun
rights we've actually been extraordinary
effective in terms of driving down gun
homicides in this country and has
nothing to do with that debate it has to
do with better policing Economic
Opportunity you know attacks on drug
gangs and things like that there's
actually a lot of learning and if we
really cared about the ultimate outcome
we'd spent a lot more time to figure out
how to do things like Boston did on the
pulling levers program and less about
this argument about whether wait a
minute do you need an assault weapon ban
because that actually has relatively
effective anything yeah so when people
are talking about guns this is I mean to
me this is one of the ones where we've
really cordoned ourselves off yeah it's
we're almost at the place of ban or
everyone gets a bazooka I definitely
fall more on the side of I strongly
believe in the Second Amendment and I
don't think that the murders that we
have necessarily our gun issues I mean
even the guy to your point about the
laws that the guy last month that shot
the church in Texas yeah it was illegal
for him to get a gun right so there were
laws in place so it's like we can keep
making more laws but that doesn't mean
people won't keep breaking laws and that
that seems to be the disconnect I think
where the left is will just make more
laws and we can actually whittle away
and all of this and for me it's like I
don't see how more laws actually resolve
this actually complicated so so the
Sutherlands bringing church slain as you
described are was evocative me because
where I went pig hunting was about eight
miles from from Gonzales Texas as the
crow flies about thirty minutes thirty
miles in 30 minutes by car and that's
actually one of the things is you know
you don't have a cop around the corner
you know beat cop around the corner like
you do in washing you see reminds me of
the the the t-shirt I saw a gun shows
which is I'd rather have a gun in my
hand and a cop on the phone but it's you
know it's evocative because it has so
much it sort of bowels up so much of the
challenge which is we clearly have a
problem look we have a you know a mass
shooting and more importantly we have
urban shootings every day and we you
know even though we've had successes we
still are way we have far more violent
society than other similar situated
countries say in Western Europe yeah for
people that wanted to know a little more
about that I mean just Google just how
many people were shot in Chicago this
weekend yeah I mean they keep it running
down right and that has nothing to do
with assault weapons or you know
registration laws because it's almost
all handguns and almost all guns
obtained illegally we've so so so we
have a problem so let's all acknowledge
it there's a really sort of a horrible
public policy problem but nothing that
we talk about actually would solve it
and you know in southern Springs you've
a guy who got his gun shouldn't have got
his gun and then he was ultimately
crowded by a you know a private citizen
who lawfully had a gun and you know
probably stopped potentially stop worst
killings so it's complicated issue and I
think we because we're all in our you
know arm bubbles talking to each other
we miss the nuance and don't really try
to solve the problem because it's
solvable yeah we've actually solved it
in some ways
[Music]
you